[Music]
so much what kind of good for you guys
to hear because this is the first place
that you came as a couple the first
award show so does it feel kind of good
every time you come back warm and fuzzy
yes is our stepping-out party no it's
cool I love this award show it's always
fun and sort of loose it's a you know
definitely a little bit more of a
free-spirited show than some of the
other ones and I love it it's anything
goes here you never know what you're
going to see and one of my favorites
glad to be here and it's kind of like
our anniversary it's awesome happy
anniversary you sort of kind of you got
a new baby at home right yes had a big
milestone this week he you did whack got
his first tooth this week so I was
wondering why he was so just not happy
crank the last few days and then he got
a tooth and I figured it out so you know
but see think he was probably to get the
other one here any day now and maybe
we'll be back to him being content for a
minute we'll see how your other kids
adjusted in the new baby I love him the
girls are actually great with him I was
I was just saying earlier sometimes
we'll get to looking for him and can't
find him and the 10 year olds got him in
there changing his diaper doing all of
this they've been a built-in babysitter
huge Hills they've been a huge Oh
[Music]
you